we're always like to start is our didn't
Matt Collinwood get into the the world
of recruitment talk to me about that
okay I would love to have an exciting
story about it yeah but I think most
people are stumbled into it okay so I I
left school at 80 at college at 18 okay
with high levels and I think it was a
time and coming from a family that the
university was simply doctors and
engineers would do so minute pal when I
was 18 launched their own little
business really yes we work in a garden
center to the same particular exciting
but we used to get like wealthy families
that would come in and they'd buy these
fish tanks and pauses and being
entrepreneurial eighteen year olds me
and my pearl would go to go to the
houses and install fish tanks and we do
maintenance contracts so little bit like
contract recruitment today that
recurring revenue but I got to about
kind of 2021 thought this is a career
that I want forever once were kind of
big bucks and arrested with a
recruitment agency a guy called Gabby
Chalmers interesting 22 years on I'm
still in contact with the guy really is
brilliant so I went along to Tony to be
with the business called computer people
market leaders back back in a day just
simply firt for interview practice and
probably about half an hour decided that
recruitment was a career that I
definitely want to go down really just
blow it away I love the idea of like
selling a product where the customer
makes the decision and the products
never going to be different I love the
idea of recruitment where two different
minds perhaps sometimes on complete
different pages you've got to convince
these guys and when they're both right
for each other
so just just a quick one before we go
into the recruitment piece I'd love to
just like how how easy was it know what
I'm interested in is when you decided to
start that business and there's 18
mm-hmm now how many people around you
was starting businesses you got I mean
because I think into that like me
growing up it's become cooler to become
a entrepreneur and these types of things
and also the people that you have access
to and how were connected now like was
I'll just I'll just curious about that
is maybe a bit curious there
like how because how much information
you have access to to try make that a
success to go I'm in we totally winged
it that's what I'm in we hadn't got a
clue what we doing I mean what we we
knew umph
we knew having worked in scorn sense for
years we know all about looking after
the fish and get in the nitrate balances
right and the pH or the rest of it but
running a business we hadn't got a clue
we just happen to be pretty good at what
we did and the business just came in but
whereas a lot of my pals were either
working in their kind of production line
the land rover my employer locally or
gone off to university may might my pal
were only really good bucks would seem
like good money back then being our own
bosses and we were the ones that were
rockin up at the bars head to toe in
massage the brand back then and I went
in bought a Porsche 94 turbo for my
birthday
really was a bit of an older car but
didn't cost me that much at the time it
was a bit of status thing then yeah I
mean it's again totally different than
when like the the if I it's sort of back
then I'm assuming from what I understand
if you had that type of coral or a
decent car like you had there's no like
getting out in finance or leasing it on
the zoom in back then we bought in cash
typically if again it was it was a
statist thing that if you have if you
had a decent car that typically meant on
that's doing all right yeah whereas now
if you want to spend four hundred quid a
month with your salary on getting the
latest car you can do that you know I
mean it's interesting um just I was just
interest in that so do you think that so
where did that come from that
entrepreneurial spirit was it did that
was that just natural to go into that
because I'm sure that's helps you
throughout your career equipment and
we'll see now now starting recruitment I
haven't um recruitment business as well
I don't I don't necessarily come from a
family where anyone's ran their own
businesses or anything like that and
good long-term jobs but always growing
up I aspired to do well I always wanted
to travel one of the big house oh I know
that quite a lot of material things burn
they're things that in order to achieve
I'd either needed to work hard yeah be
creative in terms of what I what I doing
my aspirations for years
were to set up and run my own business
mmm I was probably a little bit late in
setting up so I probably said a lil bit
of catching up to do
okay so joins and so they are they were
part of a deck at that point or how did
that work no so we going back so I
joined computer people in 1997 okay and
they were bought by deco in 99 whoo yeah
probably deco are the largest recruiting
businesses in the world so a lot of
their growth over the years to be done
through acquisition or acquisition okay
and what and then from what market did
you go into have you always been in the
same similar sort of market where you
are now or always I take really always
i.t so I've kind of flirted over the
years of looking at other market but I
know IT really well if there comes a day
where Vickie you have got like a 90%
share of IT recruitment in the UK then
it'd be time to look at somewhere else
you know we've got 0.01 or whatever it
is I just think we can beside two
incredibly well for looking at the
market
the beauty of IT is were only becoming
more and more IT savvy we driven by apps
on mobile phones I can't imagine any
time soon that I t's going to be slowing
down be a daily thing okay and then just
to I'm really keen to get on to this
sort of journey and the things that
you've learned and having your own
recruitment business but so you worked
for for that business for 17 years I
certainly linked yeah yeah and what was
just helped frame art for people
listening was it the typical route of
joining as a consult and then you become
a manager at some point then you become
a director or was that the route that
you followed or what was there pretty
much pretty much so I started ISM I
started to root as a resource er okay I
joined I was hired by a guy called Adam
Fletcher okay you might know the name
he's in the M&A space he just his career
was just transitioning through from
being in sales through to management
role so it's the perfect opportunity for
me to start as a resource and drag I
that was fast tracking his career clean
oh good recruiter at the time and he was
going off the tools so I the opportunity
to resource into some great accounts I
kind of look back at that first year of
sawsan having working good quality
accounts and a strong leader really
enabled me I think enabled me to really
fast-track my career really getting the
tools very quickly lots of exposure to
different types of tech and you know
similar was well respected so I was able
to taking out a lot to client meetings
and got a lot of face time so was your
bit I'm quite a good mentor to you then
early on you might hear this so yeah
really good really good starting out a
tyrant sometimes really really high
standards a kind of management style
that might not exist these days be as
accepted but you know kind of back in
the day it was great and it certainly
worked for me and was it easy for you at
that point was you it was the mindset
towards that just to be a sponge and
really soak up everything that's going
around
yeah it's not everyone that's not easy
to do all the time is it no so I am and
more and more recruiters coming into the
market I'll talk to them and often they
wanted to be there way
yeah there's even some some they think
they know better which is fine I kind of
look back when I started my career and I
looked around the office and those that
were doing well you could see from the
board's he was performing and I would
listen to what they were doing well
these are styles I don't ask them
questions or ask specifically for
training so I think the sponge would be
a great analogy for that and I gotta be
honest right my Korean with 27 20 years
into the industry now I've always
surrounded myself with people that I can
learn from and you've consciously done
that totally yeah absolutely that's such
good advice because it's tip one of the
most common things that I get to ask
people that come on the show is hisham
of I've hit a bit of a plateau where I'm
at the hundred fifty K might want to get
to the break the 200k mark on the 250 K
Mart when I break the 300 K market
cetera and a lot of the time the advice
does come down to that is like okay well
firstly who within your business is
doing more than you are that you can
learn from and again are you being
proactive and saying look my lot I'm
really impressed with what you're doing
or whatever like how how are you doing
that and that should be proactive within
your business it sound advice in a bit
it's quite easily not done
totally I think the question I'd ask is
anyone who's sitting in the office who
do they look up to and respect in that
office who are they learning from and if
the answer is no one then they need to
find someone other individual could be
externally to the business so if they're
just not getting it at all the only way
they're gonna advance is to go
externally yeah okay what I'd love to do
this for you to share because we'd
talked spoke about very briefly we've
got the very retro kit behind us for
those that can't see us say what how old
what year is at that so this is a
Macintosh SC 30 from 1999 brick phone a
think brick phone yet so wild love just
to share cuz if I think of the people
that I've had on this podcast over the
last 10 15 episodes and probably
definitely haven't been in a game as
long as you have so I'd like what was
recruitment like when in those sort of
first 1997 to 2000 or whatever war is
that shock because you're saying you as
fax Ian TVs and all these types of
things and like that is just mental to
me and sort of inside you know I mean
what was actually like back then and
yeah
it was a very different world I kind of
got in just the right time because I
think it was over 12-month period where
the industry took a massive change see
its continued to change since that time
but we had no email mmm we had no
website in 97 so if a candidate want to
send their CV and he's either done by
post which would take two or three days
to come in
you'd have to persuade them to come in
and drop it in face to face or their fax
it in and if you remember what quality
of faxes looked like back in the day but
they were dreadful I mean sometimes you
can't even read the text when they come
here the fax and obviously the way you
get them in front of your customers to
fax them again and after something to
speak faxed a few times it starts to
lose a bit of the quality very few
people had mobile phones the way we'd
reach candidates was pages was one way
we would would often call people at
their home numbers really they didn't
have Mobile's that we'd expect the
partner to answer you'd hope and pray
the part that would answer the phone
and let's say for example it was the
wife that answered he'd be telling her
what a great job we have fella and we
spending more time with the kids
earning a lot more money and then the
first thing she'd make him do when he
got home was to call up the recruitment
agency because we were reliance on those
guys calling us back and obviously we
don't live in that we didn't live in
that kind of mobile world that we do
today we'd be in the office most
evenings till 8 o'clock waiting for the
phone to ring yeah and for the
candidates to call us so in your time in
recruitment then talking about that what
whoa what was the love the biggest
change would you say like what I had the
big I've seen oh it's always changing
these lots of things but you talking
about it there then what had that was
was internet the biggest thing like what
had the biggest impact on the change of
the market and how you approach things
there's a few things that have changed
it I think it's changing for the better
room for the worse at the same time so
we take the internet we take email yeah
emails fantastic can do they can get me
their CV in a matter of seconds on a
client's desktop in seconds so that's
sped the whole process up mmm which is
great you know time kills deals not the
rest of it but I think to the detriment
of actually picking up the phone mmm so
again too many crews these days were
live very heavily on emails LinkedIn
messages all the rest of it I'm a
massive advocate picking up the phone
and calling your customers and like I
say back in the day where the really
good CV we'd jump in the car and drive
and see the clients grab the clients say
these are the CV these the candidates
that you need to interview and I just
think that that technology's helped us
massive labor to the detriment is
sometimes that personal touch I think I
think for me is so I'm I'm I would like
live and breathe on LinkedIn and I now
help but crews get more I've LinkedIn
and for me it has to be both for me I
like like it just has to be both and
that that's something that's really big
for me and and I think now it's even got
that far the what you're just talking
about there where I think for me I think
the people that can be really proactive
and a great at building relationships on
the phone and these types of things and
now gonna have even more of a
competitive answer it's all gonna go
back on itself if you go I'm in because
there's so many people out there to do
just hide behind emails and just send
glows of messages each day etcetera
etcetera which means as probably less
people now actually be really proactive
on the phone
and building those relationships that
they need to so I think I think there's
going to be a real but there's such a
good opportunity for people if they
can't get that online piece right and
then that that drive sales conversations
and great but also if you're someone
that is like your Center pick up the
phone very proactive you can still
that's still really fruitful work do you
know I mean I think simply like me
that's been in the game for 22 years
which was you know coming a time where
there's no social media yeah no emails I
can adopt and work to that standard then
you know I'd like to think that those
coming into it or have perhaps don't
even know in that world can pick the
phone and he'll come or you know go out
and see more of their customers and
develop those personal relationships on
top of top of social media so have you
so you didn't met you didn't mention so
when you got into this world of
recruitment did you always did you then
really feel like that what this was
gonna be the vehicle for you to start
your own business I know if you
previously started my own business and
bought lots of cars and all that but I
kind of always said that I spent 17
years with one business which is a hell
of a long time what they're really good
at is getting a golden handcuffs on you
you know once it was difficult to get
away from that but I'd always said that
if I was gonna leave it was to either
set up on my own or to move at the
industry completely and do something
else yeah I never found something else
that really got my interest as much as
what recruitment didn't without mean to
sound an arrogant way simply got did and
did very well exactly so why not stick
at it it was just it come at the right
time five years ago launched evq
m-m-m-marry in the financial position
but also you know emotionally with it
and the only and all certainly wouldn't
call it great regret they're probably
the only thing I wish that had done he's
probably just 35 years earlier really
because I was ready to yeah a little bit
of risk on it I'm kind of one of things
I do with her with the business coaches
look at where my strengths and areas
improvement are and the one the one
thing that yes might say would have
helped me back he's just being risk
averse really so yeah so I'm kind of
aware of that now and in some some
occasions it can be a great help you
know there's it has a detrimental effect
so I'm kind of getting that balance
because one thing on is one it's art I
know you mentioned it there that they
yeah you said that the golden handcuffs
there but what do you think
they did really work because how many
people do you see now that have worked
for one business in recruitment for 17
years you know I mean so I guess how how
do you think they what what do you think
they did really well which we do which
probably businesses or people can think
of that they can use themselves to
retain people know business ago I mean
what do you think are some of the things
they did really well to keep Matt in
that business I don't know whether it
was the business that kept me or I kept
the business on really yes so I mean
talking around great company to work
sure sure yeah great career company's
biggest building in its history kind of
there was a time that sort of time would
I get wheeled out to meet a lot the
trainees as the example of what can be
done but you know I kind of think that
was he necessarily the business that
kept me there I think it was me kept
myself there with a high salary in the
thought of you know I kind of started
buying property and it's a thought being
able to service the loans on those yes
it's a few holidays a year and the nice
cars and a certain lifestyle and looking
after family or whatever and it was just
being able to step away from that that
made sense obviously is very quickly the
responsibilities can stack up can't they
compared to five years ago what you had
to think about what you had to pay what
who you had to support it cetera that
Quebec and quickly James Caan it yeah so
you mentioned there I was to you was you
was one of the higher performance in
that that group or that yes so I I was I
was computer people's be Spiller it's
really true so I did one point four five
million in my best year well GP that's
meant it was great yeah that's good
there's that per mille contract its
contract okay so I know exactly that
done kind of similar sort of things and
stuff but yes sir noise I was I think a
good recruit for me can do about half a
million quid seven hundred something
like those Monica a good contract biller
and the server is that is that your
bread and butter contract Robin yeah so
we 90 percent as we're not % GP as a
business okay
but in sad to do that by the way it's
just that I think we do so my
co-director guy called Mike where cut
with contract together
been doing there for what 14 years so
I've even set up a business with some
guys really good at contract there we go
good contract business just on that
point that's big mate thank you so that
I mean that that's a great achievement
and what year was that in 2003 okay just
I'm sure there's loads that went into it
and and then we'll sort of dive into
this or vqn in these things but I have I
have to ask you like what how let's
break that down a bit like what that
year I'm sure there's a lot of things
that contributed to it but how the hell
did you get to that point of what are
some of the key things that you think
really enable you to achieve that
because that's I mean there's not many
many people doing that now as you said
and I think there's definitely gonna be
some key learnings there that probably
become habitual to you but what were
some of the key things do you think the
neighbor used to do that okay so I'd
always relatively well so okay as a
contract bailout always do between I
four and six hundred grand a year
yeah which was good and it's gonna sell
beer and I remember though with my
director at the time a guy called Nick
and saying to him I really want to build
big yeah Fraser come at ya bill big and
his response back was okay so you need
to be contract because like yes and it
says the most simple conversation that
at the time but he said who has the most
contractors and I said well it will be
the likes of HP EDS neutronics at the
time which was the big kind of
high-volume infrastructure guys further
doing lots of infrastructure refresh is
there was a smooth beginning for
companies to move to the cloud etc and
where virtual environment as simple as
he said it was just targeting those
sorts of businesses and what I did was
mapped out who the key companies were
then mapped out he the head of
professional services were within those
companies and started rich netted and
the model was pretty simple what I'd
have these teams of server network cloud
guys where there was a project manager
there was architects in there there was
the engineers and pretty much as one
project was scaling down with one
business I'd literally pick up a whole
team and drop them into another clients
so it was a ready-made team
the individuals knew each other he was a
great cell that no other recruiters
doing when they talked about just simply
going in with ones and twos yeah so that
was the kind of solution he was
identifying the customers with the
volume and actually having quiet and he
was a USP back then there was no one
else that was offering that the kind of
big product bird but big project teams
like that I had a plan internally which
was to build my own infrastructure of
people that could support me and that
was always done through resources so
whereas I do most of the client facing
stuff I had resources that would do a
lot of the the candidate agent yeah
which is great which would work really
well so - but are you say between about
two for two in for resources and then as
they do want a resource in I was able to
move this through to consultancy roles
as well so keep them really great
footing just like show me the the
opportunity I had to go see yeah these
guys have exactly the same and I said
the only other thing and they might be a
bit of a boring response to you I've
always had a high work I think yeah so I
was really important to point out that
you know I think a lot of people want to
succeed and they want to do the right
things but you know the nature of having
to get high results sometimes results in
high work ethic to do that so I you know
I'd work often work Saturdays and
Sundays and we can see fact one of the
accounts I've been chipping away for
about two years
yeah I got a call about 4:30 on a Friday
evening from to say that his customer
ABN AMRO wanted 22 Desktop guys just to
do a patch work down at bishops gate and
I said he said I've got to speak to my
uses leave with me absolutely commit
that these guys will be there on Monday
morning when he needed them I worked my
whole weekend and he phoned me up on a
Monday morning and he said Matt I asked
for 22 engineers and I thought it's been
a disaster none of the return a.b said
24 of them have turned up and basically
what I've done is I factored into more I
thought two guys are going to drop out
and he said I didn't think you'd be able
to get more than 22 but we could do it
some more but the message there was it
was just it was around work grafting
that whole weekend and this project that
these guys were doing this patchwork was
just one week
we make very very little money but what
it did was he sent the right message out
to the customer that we were committed
and were able to deliver Balu and we
went from a business that give us no
work at all to wander them work with us
on exclusive basis yeah so I think and
do you think that's or do you think that
still of stands now and what what I mean
by that you mentioned there before you
went into it a good contract Billy
coming 507 okay or bill that like do you
think that advice or that approach we
still stand now in terms of actually
take a step back from it and look at it
counsel you do have who in your market
are the big players and can offer that
that big project work to go I mean do
you think that still sound advice I
completely the message is even before
hitting the big businesses he's just to
have a plan
mmm so I think the markets changed a
little bit from the early 2000s now to
single digit margins whereas my started
with a two and then and a lot there was
an eternal recruitment but I think what
sits before that is just to have a plan
of a plan a plan could be and this is
where the the market is today and it's
not going to change is just go
specialist so go in each wide and a mile
deep into a specialization so find
something that's in each and just boss
that boss that market know all your
contractors within that space and meet
with them talk to them on a regular
basis they'll tell you who's moving and
and and clients that have got projects
within that space and GS stay just stay
loyal to that to that market and he'll
come interest them so how many people
did you start Vicky with so there was
five of us on day one yeah we have we've
grown this 20 of us now 23 million yeah
so I had this conversation quite
recently where a lot of recruitment
owners I talked to the when they talked
about their business the first thing
they talk about is the size of their
business and that yes yeah exactly and I
think ed cat for me Ivana T whereas you
know the bottom line is sanity so from
the the 20 people we've got in the biz
at the moment we've got average 200k per
year in income yeah in five years of
trading we've only lost one person
really at one person levy I'm gonna work
for the competition
okay so we're able to hold and you know
these people want to work for us so it
must be doing something right but we've
got no women got aspirations to be a
fifty a hundred FTE business mmm
for us it's just about finding the right
people and and having those continue
working for us no I think that's a
really valid point I think in in the
world of obviously that the type of
industry is and what it's renowned for
the money you can make and the nice
things you can buy and stuff I think
what what you point them out there is
okay headcount is is is a number that we
should be looking at however it
shouldn't be the core metric that we
should be thinking about it's this the
things that you just highlight there the
net fee income how many people will be
retained in these types of things and I
think that that should be what people
should be thinking about you go I'm in
rather than let's get five more people
in getting billing 100k that's fine okay
on to the business school I mean or we
might lose two people so then we need
that that type of approach that's really
interesting so have you always when when
you start the business then how how was
it did did you had to deal with any like
covenant something like that or did you
wait a decent amount of period before
you could crack on with that like was
there any challenges with that with that
or was it okay so the firm they're worth
work for weren't particularly happy okay
although just to be clear I did I done
nothing wrong yeah so there was no claim
that I hasten anything like that did you
have a business plan I had a business
plan and all of you guys had that always
it more you're doing with that or so I I
was responsible for lot more in strategy
in the guys and I helped helped
implement that strategy okay and then so
I guess you said there that you never
had aspirations to be big big a big big
big agency has that always remained then
all of you sort of had to has that
changed the massive change so you asked
me about a year and a half ago we don't
want to be honest said 5050 people
sitting legal or the rest of you just
purely round numbers
the early part last year we went on a
big campaign hire a lot of people in and
we got up to 28 people okay and
obviously as I say we'd add to 20 so
some didn't work out I see that as a
personal failure hmm so the individuals
didn't necessarily deliver to the extent
of the business needed to and they're no
longer with us but you know any people
don't work out it's it's my fault
because I choose to hire those people
I'm responsible for training them up
it's very easy I hate so many managers
if staff don't work out to say well that
person was an idiot or something like
that well I said have you always had
that one set a hundred percent I never
said he was I remember back in the day
big corporate world board meetings they
go around the room and everyone be
slighting their snap my fingers totally
and it's like well the only idiot is the
person who hires them and keeps them so
I think that's such good advice
to really live and breathe that if you
have your own recruitment business like
anyone that you hire that doesn't work
out it's your fault no one else's I
think that's really it so what did you
learn through that period then in terms
of in terms of you as you said you
wanted 50 60 heads got to 28 20 what
what would this kilo because there'll be
a lot of people listening that want to
start their recruitment business or I've
started in the thinking I want to grow
this I want to get it to 15 20 30 heads
or whatever what was some of the key
learnings think this there was a lot of
learning learning points out of that to
be honest with you I think the key B 2
is just hire the right people slow to
hire quick to fire it's a it's a well
used phrase man it's it should it should
be the standard for most businesses so
one of things were implemented over the
last 12 months he's been edgy
psychometric testing for all on Reuters
that coming to the business and it is
fantastic what this product does is the
candidate one of our potential recruiter
for us sits down and completes this
assessment you'll take about 45 minutes
an hour but he feeds back on what their
strengths scenario of improvement is it
doesn't tell you whether you should go
and hire this person or but what it will
do is it all where the arrows in pruvit
are it provides some questions to ask
and you know the really good open base
open questions and when I've used those
questions they it's gone one of two ways
if the candidate has been able to
explain this very well and they've been
you
chance and those people have come good
or you can see them really struggling
with the answers and it's at that point
it's the answer to the questions made my
mind up in terms of what our
decision-making process is but moving it
forward I was really interested in and
have you done that psychometric tests on
the people in your business now we have
myself as well which is great yeah
because and then that gives you some
real talent dates or was there any
common themes that you noticed it's it's
it's totally different really people
yeah it is completely because the
certain strengths and weaknesses and
then identify but there isn't it the
reason there isn't a standard blueprint
yeah so I think I can't I think this
came up once before and when they did it
on the people in their business there
was like one or two sort of things that
were quite common that came out of it so
then that obviously it's a it's a it
gives you actually quit do some real
data there actually get all these people
in our business hitting the mark around
this that's probably something that we
should be looking out for in new hires
okay that's interesting so I guess
that's that's an interesting sort of
failure that you've learnt through and
then that's made you sort of reflect on
more actually what were our goals here
and I guess as you as you were saying
before it's enabled you to actually be
in a position where you're actually
getting more out of the people in your
falls and then your business rather than
thinking about how many more people can
we add to the headcount to go I'm in so
what what are some of the things that
you've done to get more out of your
people has it been very much the
learning development piece and investing
heavily in that or how have you gone
about maximizing actual people within
your business to go I mean yeah I think
you know if I look back at my career I
didn't wake up in the morning think I've
got to make my employer a lot of money
anyone does yeah so it's I've always had
a planner something I want to achieve my
life is reason something that's driving
me together a bit when I'm working for
someone or now whilst and working for
myself and one of the things I've always
done with the guys you just understand
what makes them tick what gets them out
of it so it could be one of the guys
he's getting married and December
this year and one of the key things for
him he's when he joined he had an idea
of what wedding aid would look like and
actually if he had if he achieve certain
goals and certain you know he's kind of
growth plans what wedding B would look
like he's well on tractor to have the
the dream wedding which is great it's
it's kind of just focusing in so it's
not coming into work to hit a target or
to make the employer happy but actually
what our that one moment yeah totally
and how do you how come people will
start digging if they don't know that so
if Matt's in my team right now and I
don't know what makes him tick how can I
start approaching that conversation to
go I'm in just need to see make Polly
just need to sing get close to their
people
hmm so whether we done through a regular
review or just sitting your staff down
over a beer and understanding what what
kind of makes them tick but I think any
manager who's focused on purely what the
business wants and what the business
needs to get is he's coming from
completely wrong angle ya know look at
what you know look at what they've mber
want someone what to say the colleague
want to get out of it I think it's come
up a few times this because I think look
you can you can rule that person with
you need to be doing this amount of
activities to get this that are there
but it's come a few times or actually
when once you know when this certain
person really wants to provide have a
wedding of his dreams and these types of
things when when things get tough and
you're having conversations on like what
can we do to improve in these types of
things it's something that you can use
to motivate these people I mean so it's
like you know you know you had that
conversation tell me that you want to
achieve this wedding or you want to get
that how how we're going to do that or
what did you go I mean it's also
something that you can all say from what
people have said and shared it's also
really useful to understand how to
motivate their team as well that's
bigger than look we agreed that these
were the KPIs and you haven't hit them
did you know I mean it's different
we don't do KPI so you know we don't
even do targets so that's a lot overall
annual yeah so the business as a target
yeah but in terms of the guys aren't
given a target at all so really the way
we base everything around a pledge so I
know for me for me KPIs are amazing I
absolutely love
kpi but he's probably the worst
management style to manage by a KPI low
okay because what managers tend to do is
they'll coming to be people around their
head for not doing something so what we
have is ever we have a huddle every
morning so the team sit down it or
factly stand at 8:30 and everyone just
talks what the gonna talks to what
they're gonna do that day it's why I
have this particular job I need to cover
it off or I'm only to focus around any
business and on a Monday morning people
play John what they're gonna do so I
need to focus on new business so I need
to connect with 30 customers this week
I'm going to arrange a couple of
meetings so the guys are pledging and
they're dictating how they're going to
run their week mmm and they all also
pledge their activity so I will increase
my contract book by 500 quid or a grand
or something like that this month so no
one in the room can ever say that the
targets were too high and there was no
reason why anyone shouldn't deliver on
what they've committed to doing
obviously if somebody's coming in their
whole plan for the week ease get to get
to sales calls and a CVA at the door
then they're gonna get challenged yeah
challenged by the manager they get
challenged by their colleagues
hmm wide use that work pleasure that's
an interesting word of choice yeah its
commitment its commitment liked it yeah
it's it's been it's been the pledge
board it's I just I think we'd give
someone a target there within their
rights to push back and say you don't
know my business well enough that target
is unrealistic when people are pledging
committing to what they're gonna do
there's no reason why they shouldn't be
able to deliver that I like that we
family gets more results yeah because if
it's well again it's coming back to I'm
not this is bigger than just me doing
this format because it means that his
business it means it gets more net for
income it's it's one pledging to do it
because I'm creating the targets and the
ambitions that I want for me do you not
I mean that's interesting and so just to
run them off knowing what you know now
then what do you look for in the hire
what are the key sort of characteristics
that you look for that you just don't
like if they don't have this this and
this I'm not interested because I've
learned enough this it's not gonna it's
probably a very high chance it's not
gonna work out what the key
characteristics you look for you know
what it's I think having done this for
so long I think it does make you good
character and I think a lot of the
judgments outside of doing things like
psychometric testing at CBI are probably
done unconsciously okay
which I know probably isn't an answer to
what you're looking for but the traits
generally and we look for this when we
do our competency based interviewing
it's just things like passion and energy
I want to hear people that are
passionate about something in life yeah
if you'd simply go outside of work maybe
the work that maybe the kids just the
vehicle the oh-yo and - what they want
if they're passionate about recruitment
or doing their job happy days that's
great we'll look at things like previous
sales experience and how they've gone
about doing that so I've made some great
salespeople but actually they're great
with accounts that people have given
them mmm and we're a new business
company we've got two contractors for
every every client growls - growl - new
to their tool and expand across these
customers but we've got such a big
portfolio of customers because the guys
driving the levels of new business
mm-hmm so we need people to go and
secure that so again new business is a
important trait that sales piece we look
at people that are flexible one of
questions we might ask is giving example
of when you've worked outside a core
hours so coming back to the point I
mentioned about yeah
working a weekend or evening now you
don't have to do that but I can
guarantee there's a Mack Collingwood in
another recruitment business that will
be talking to your customer and we'll
fill your effort is being done I only
think it's that whole passion energy
ability to sell the main the main trait
that we look for and again this is
probably not one that I can necessarily
quantify is it's having individuals the
fit into what is the vq mold we've got
no ego upstairs yeah there's no attitude
individuals like that wouldn't look
wouldn't last five minutes we've got a
bunch of people there really ciao well
they love they get on really well with
each other they loved the v/q trips that
we do where we take them overseas and
stuff whereas I don't think you know
that level of enjoyment if you just
focused on individuals that can make
money yeah I didn't fit that that kind
of mold and how long do you reckon it's
taken you to understand well that vq mod
is again I know it's quite intangible
but you know I mean you know it I don't
think I'm there yet still really I don't
know so it's always always
learning mmm but I did have a vision on
day one in terms of what that look like
yeah but it's evolved and will continue
to evolve wholly I spend more time with
the people in the office and I deal with
my family it's just the nature of doing
any sort of job so it's really important
that you know those people like me I
like them and you know we can all get
along hmm what I'd love to go into now
is because you did you just touch them
at them and so one of the another real
common thing that people ask me to speak
to people about is is new business in
business development so I think what I'd
love to sort of get your perspective on
is so in in your business now have you
got some 300 400 500 k contract builders
yeah okay good that's great in this
market right what a view so let's talk a
bit about some of the common things that
you see in these people that maybe some
people listening that are on this or
around the 200 K mark or whatever has
contract billa's what what are the
common things that you see in in these
people that hitting those sort of
numbers so one of the one of things I
said very early on was about the lost
skill of actually picking up the phone
and hating people mm-hmm I think what
wraps around that is just networking
yeah networking is it's a it's a word
that I think people use but it's not
necessarily a skillet I see people
demonstrating along month so networking
for me is when you talk to a candidate
very early on keeping in contact with
that individual actually following them
on their journey and working with them
to understand who they know and how you
can help them and they can help you in
return so if I look at a lot of our
clients at the moment a large percentage
and it's a good 40-plus percent have
come off the back of referrals so either
way they've done an amazing job for a
client that clients gone elsewhere and
introduced us to they're a new ink or
we've done a really good job I can today
and they've landed somewhere else so
that as a senior appointment they've
hired from us so for me the whole
business new business thing is you could
be a half a million quid biller in this
industry by never making a cold call at
all by just showing a great level of
engagement with every every candidate
that you talk to really interesting
point I think what you're talking about
there as well is surely these people
that are achieving that in your business
there's a mindset piece there where do
you know I mean it would be very easy
for some people to speak to Matt the
candidate that you can't help me right
now but I could potentially help you and
it's very easy to not think about giving
you a good experience cuz you could help
me in the years two years time you know
I mean yeah it's an interesting point if
the candidate if there's a candidate
that sent their CV through was looking
for work this is the time when they need
your help
so if you're not offering that help why
should they help you later down the line
when they no longer need your help
mm-hmm so it's just working with those
guys now I mean I I look at some of the
best relationships I've got with project
managers program managers where I've
gone through the job boards through a
job site or a job serve and I found jobs
that are suitable for them through other
recruitment agencies and I've just
pinged in that job to say look I saw
this those of you and their mind say is
well why would you want to introduce
that candidate to another recruitment
agency well when he lands who's he going
to come work with who they gonna come
work with mmm so it's just a whole
networking piece for me I think you know
in addition to that kind of new business
a more mature approach to sales is
collaborative and partnered approaches
to recruitment so we go with a lot of IT
providers ya know a lot of these IT
providers all they want to do is sell
hardware software and their consulting
services which is often a relatively
small part of IT but they'll have large
network and a large network of their own
clients
one of the solutions it's worked really
well for us is to work alongside these
customers alongside our custom which is
the app P add source business gone
meetings with them strategize with them
and their client when it comes to
recruitment
obviously that's not something that
comes overnight and you need to work at
that for months if not years but the
beauty of that is you've got your
clients doing your new business and
you'll be half mm-hmm and again it does
stem from from what you've seen is is
that networking piece and again having
that that mindset of okay well yeah
maybe this isn't going to bed
fishel me free right now but long-term
as you said that person lands that job
then all of a sudden could open up a big
account and these types of things yeah
it's a business development then that
seems like a so I was apparently buried
sir
yeah from what I've learned a contract
recruiter the BD piece that's the lucky
turn the client did you know I mean so
how effective is cold-calling now in
your I just don't love cold corner I
really I still love cold cording to a
certain extent it's just when you get
through to their individual to be able
to do something very different yeah and
I think at the moment I see too many
trainees coming in they're just told to
pick up the phone and ask people have
they got any jobs you can understand why
cold calling isn't working for them yeah
I cold call I still call callers an MD
and I still see results from it so but
my conversations with the hiring manager
the potential hiring managers at
guaranty are going to be very different
to a lot of other calls they've they've
had previously would you tend to lead
with that
so we when we first launched the
business we you know we try and grab
whatever we could win yeah through the
door and we were getting more developer
jobs than anything else and I don't even
know much about the dotnet space but
you've got twice as many jobs there's no
there's very very few candidates in the
marketplace so we wanted a different
kind of solution for this and I was chat
with a pal of mine who's an immigration
barrister and he said what are you do
you - outside of the EU and I'd seen
like candidates from years from places
like India etc yeah yeah and very long
story short we come up with a solution
whereby we would source candidates from
Vietnam for a Malaysia from the
Philippines because there's a hotbed of
some world-class developers out there
that speak fluent English whose
expectation from a salary point of view
are should we send more realistic hey
guys when they want to move and we put a
product we put it went about putting a
product in place to go into these
customers to say look we know you
looking for 2030 Vella PIRs locally
you're not going to find them you're
gonna have to be reliant on compromising
around your skill set or using costly
contractors we've got the solution where
we'll bring resourcing from overseas for
you massive
cost-savings will work with the home
office to get the tier two visas forward
then we did a full landing program but
in our to see a question about the the
new business sales calls I'll call
development managers development
directors and talk about this solution
not one of them have heard it so I think
the message is you haven't necessarily
got a sell my product it's it's paint
since it's copyrighted
but it's different it's going something
completely different and when we when we
launch that solution in order to make
sure it work properly we need a guinea
pig I couldn't really go to a client say
look we've got this wild idea so Vicky
went through our own sponsorship we
bought over a couple of developers that
work directly for us and they built a
product for us called technical
assessment code at UK which is the
development tool so I can see a
programmer in front that tool and you'll
tell me how good they are well as a
full-stack developer it tests their
front end back in database etc they're
quite common to have them sometimes the
interview processes aren't there yeah
they are they are I think that some
clients will be the standard across
their business yeah but we my developers
built out this product so we go into
customers and we'll say look you could
make this part of your recruitment
process and for that we want to be a
supplier and actually we want to get all
your contract business exclusive but
actually wouldn't be really fun to start
testing your own developers to see what
their strengths and weaknesses are so
we've got clients that are using this
across their business now is their
standard for any they're hiring just
like I meet you with the psychrometric
that we use and as part of their reviews
with their own permanent developers so
really interesting
so again just coming back to coming back
to the new business approach he's
picking up the phone to these customers
and these solutions neither might not be
right but you know what the client will
remember mmm no I think that often
that's amazing mate that you come up
with that solution and I think as we
were saying before we started this is
how recruitment is changed in these
types of things I think like from what I
understand the conversation I'm having
if you want to future-proof your
recruitment business its solutions like
you've got a really calm print to the
table real solutions as you said
something better than just ones and twos
and I well yeah yeah Matt will work
you've got you have one vacancy let me
fill it and it's actually GOI mints I
think that's I think that's amazing
take the good part of it as well you get
to fly I mean best uu with you your
customer for five days a week power
you're either interview during the day
you're at for dinner on the evening or
something like that but there's no
better way to develop those
relationships further and also you get a
Sun Tan very nice so I'm just conscious
they're a big thing for me with this
podcast it is really talking about the
this all really are actually uncovering
the sort of true fairies learnings and
these types of things so I guess what
what I'd love you to talk a bit about is
like well have when have you experienced
some real tough times may I think a bit
Gretz just touched on that some of the
times that you really had to dig deep to
push through if any like has there at
what comes to mind when there's been
some little difficult times for you and
this business that you've really had to
push through which there'll be a lot of
people listening that I've gone through
even it just has a bit of that it can be
really unforgiving this job do you know
I mean so what comes to mind when I ask
you that yeah it's actually it's always
been it's always been manageable so that
fair enough I will give an example so
most people think being self-employed
means that you can lie bedroll in a ten
eleven o'clock and some people can do
that if they want to but in five years
of trading I had never been late so I
lead by example standing with the guys
there's never been a day I've got up and
I thought I don't want to go in today so
there's been there's been days I've gone
home and said I'm not gonna go in
tomorrow yeah I think I'm really good at
leaving the baggage and then coming in
the next day to fresh day refocusing and
if it's a Casey getting at plan dust me
down and fixing it and stuff but don't
get me wrong there are highs and lows I
mean thankfully for us the highs have
been allies been a lot higher yeah but
if I you know probably the biggest low
point for me was the the way we launched
this this business was to we lose five
of us on day one it was quite costly
who
costly launch for us because we've got
all experienced recruiters within rent
offices we went and bought a building in
central Birmingham just to kind of send
the right statement out to the market we
spent a small fortune on on websites etc
but we funded the whole thing through
debt okay so we got a glorified
overdraft from the bank put a personal
guarantee against it which meant that if
we didn't pay off the debt then we were
selling houses so to make it happen and
so from day one a launch in fact from
day minus 30 we'd already spent a
fortune on day one we're just
hemorrhaging cash in for the first month
even the first year we just did a
massive loss as a business I remember
looking into it after a year of thinking
what have I done here yeah I own an
obscene amount of money to the bank if
I'm not able to make this work I'm back
I'm downsizing yet to simple as that so
that was a bit of a low but that was
just revisiting the reasons why I did it
in the first place just injecting a bit
self-confidence there actually this is
the lowest part we're going to go
through and we're at the break-even
point and everything else is you then
you're to just paying off the debt and
motoring on I think that I talk to a lot
of people that maybe been in the
corporate world or working from other
business and they want to become
self-employed they want to go and do
their own thing and what they see is
businesses you know on social media
training themselves incredibly well and
all the exciting stuff and trips for
their people and getting involved
exciting things about branding exercises
and csr and all that kind of stuff often
what they don't realize well they don't
focus on ease going through that journey
of racking up a ton of debt or the
disasters that go on and when you lose
when you get a drop out very early on
it's dreadful I mean it's it can be
that's the sort of stuff that keeps you
awake at night
mmm to a certain extent but a touchwood
at the moment we haven't had any
disasters in the business I think if we
had a disaster today I'd go home and I'd
probably down a bottle of red or
something like that but you become great
at managing I think that's often that's
fairness I think so have you always been
like that or like have you during this
journey or you have you just
during your life experience you've just
got coz what you're talking about there
really is its perspective as well isn't
it it's like okay I can leave like
tomorrow's a new day
it's cetera hourly things want to leave
there so I'm with my family after but
what have you done to become better at
managing because not everyone is good at
even from a biller to an owner of a
business like what what things do you do
if if any house what did you know I mean
I'm 43 now yeah Ida Ida light bulb
moment when I was 13 okay I'll share
this story with you it was my 30th
birthday no cut party I remember who
said he to me but somebody said the guy
you are 30 is the person you are for the
rest of your life okay I remember
thinking I don't want to be that saying
I want to learn evolve and all the rest
of it and I mentioned these two about
two or three other people as in actually
I didn't feel I derived I didn't and I
still doubt now and I hope I'm not when
I'm 63 and there was a very good friend
of mine Steve said have you considered
business coaching okay for me business
coaching my mindset was you go and if
somebody tells you how to run a business
and how to get the most out of your
staff and he referred me to a guy called
Richard Elwell who's a business coach
based up here in the Midlands and I went
I used to go once a fortnight this guy
and all we did for probably the first
three months we never talked business
we never was never bet actually how do I
use these and out page like Jedi he's
your coach or you love what he he was my
coach okay and he he basically told me
not to stop and the first thing he did
was Rob and teach me stuff he enabled me
to learn about myself okay what my
strengths and weaknesses are and you
know the sort of stuff think what gets
married but it sounds like a really deep
conversation but I think if you want to
get the more out of other people in our
business you've got to understand how
you get more out yourself self-aware and
exactly so one of the things we focus on
pretty early was always having a plan
and I was quite an emotive guy that
would love to have an argument go
toe-to-toe with people but actually it
was just making decisions that were more
pragmatic and actually considering
repercussions of the decisions that I
made so
I think what I did back then 30 and I
think that was the catalyst that kind of
pushed me on has helped me today and I'm
by no means the finish though and it's
always about learning so I think for
you've got to want to do it because when
I was having sessions with Richard I was
waxing lyrical to everyone about how
great it was yeah that everyone needs to
do it and a lot of my friends were going
along to think right what is all this
about and similar getting a lot out of
it but equally was a lot that just
didn't get it want it for yourself as
well exactly I think you've got to want
to change and you've got a you want to
go through that journey no I think
you've shown that I think that's great
advice I think how so I am a bit a bit
younger but I had a bit of a lightbulb
moment myself and I was like 23 and it
was simple and it was simple as the best
investment you can make in yourself
it sounds really simple but I didn't
realize that previously and I think yeah
all you're talking about there or part
of what you're talking about is is
self-awareness so when when when times
do get tough if that's you as a biller
if that's you as a business owner I
think if you've really put a lot of work
into knowing what gets you out of bed in
the morning and know more about yourself
it's gonna equip you with better tools
so you can deal with different
circumstances and challenges in target
circumstances and which already like so
keen to speech about the Canaries okay
because I think it's evident your
mindset how you approach things and is
different to the typical and recruitment
business owner that people will probably
have a perception of but what I just won
as I said before we started I was really
keen just to get your thoughts on this
and even more so considering your sort
of track record and it came up once or
twice what do you mean you may do this
in your business now but how have you
gone about I know you said how you start
your business and racked up debt and
these types of things but have you
always been quite smart with the money
that you've earn in recruitment I think
was a chap Tony that I had in this
podcast said sort of how many
we're talking to big bidders young
people about how they can maximize the
money they're earning and turn the money
you're making into assets and not just
all nice clothes and these sorts of
things to go I'm in so I guess there
were a lot of people listen in there I
earn a lot of money there maybe they're
their business or no-one's speaking some
about financial advice and financial
health to go I'm in so watch what's your
relationship with money and how have you
got better with it okay so I think the
important thing is enjoy yourself yeah
sure so I kind of look back my twenties
and traveled everywhere and yep
blew a ton of dough but yeah I don't
regret I actually enjoyed doing it kind
of run alongside that I was pretty
clever because I'd always save and it's
investing in bricks and mortar was
always smart so I bought my first
property at 23 and I had to say buddy
posit in order to do that yet cut back
and all the rest of it but I was focused
on doing that and then bought a few
properties personally and then me and my
best pal business partner we set up a
property company yeah five years ago
okay so it's not a small business but
our what we're doing is we're investing
the profits from v/q into the property
business so in the last few months we we
bought a couple of million quids worth
of commercial properties and HMOs across
the Midlands and the planets used to
keep scaling that I mean the beauty of
recruitment is you can even it you know
whether you're working as a business as
a trainee or an indie of a large
established business you can influence
your earnings by all the stuff that we
spoken about today so I would suggest to
anyone investing bricks and mortar
because you're never going to lose out
with wood property long term yeah and I
think if those that that do want to have
a nice little nest egg I think to
strategically think about how you invest
the profits from your business into into
bricks and mortar I think he's a smart
move okay
no I think it's just an interesting
point because every I think when I was
on in good money
not many it's very easy as you know
in today's day and age to get lost in
looking the best and having all the
latest things you know I mean and I
think recruitment it can fast-track your
career it can fast-track your earnings
it can also get you in a bad spot if
you're not if you're not thinking like
that and you have a lot of decent head
on your shoulders you know I mean it's
always been like that because everyone's
always wanted to wear the designer gear
or nice car and stuff like that it's
just that what is the cost of that and
how important is it to someone to earn
the road property mmm so the recruitment
canarians yeah how long has that been
going on for two years now two years
yeah and that's you and del del show get
familiar people and why did you start
that so going back to the hold life in
the corporate world
we had a HR function a trainee function
a legal function I had a peer group I
had a boss if I had a problem there was
always somebody like eternity or if I
had a problem wasn't where of it it's
always somebody that could come tap me
on the shoulder they want to launch in
it can be quite lonely at the top and
one of the things you don't want to do
is sell on the floor and say we've got
cash flow issues or we're having
problems or this is a disaster or that's
a disaster or I need help with this it's
sending out a good strong message and
leading from the front so when I
launched one of the first things I did
this is my whole thinking about
surrounding myself with people that are
good and often better than me is that I
was there to the local recruitment
network so in Bowyer's have people
around businesses some that have been
established for years and similar
perhaps going on the scent journey is
may not drop them an email and he was a
little bit random you know this guy to
say look fancy me not for coffee cuz
recruitment has been for many years and
I'm not sure if it still is no to
recruitment companies bump into each
other at a bar and there's a little bit
of attitude it's like the anchorman ease
now yeah there is an element of that
about it and recruitment shouldn't be
like that doesn't need to be like it so
it started out with about five of us and
we weren't called the Canaries we were
just five guys sharing four most willing
to be air share experiences challenges
exactly if I had a really bad day I'd
pick up the phone I'd ransom one of them
and I
saying or maybe we can without a
particularly good month or week on sales
we can share that because there's no
egos yeah in the group if simply was
getting a particularly good deal on one
of the job boards or something would
share what the best price is yeah so we
knew what we had we could negotiate and
stuff and that kind of we started
getting doing regular meetups there was
about five or six of this meta then
there's about ten or fifteen and then we
come up with the name that Canaries so
the idea is all flock together with
chirp I would talk and share that notion
yeah very random name but that's one
that people seem to seem to remember and
it's just kind of snowball from there so
we've got 50 members it's all Birmingham
bases couple just outside of Birmingham
but there's no subscription people don't
have to pay to become members there's
code of conduct we expect them to to
sign into in the first chapter that is
just around collaboration yeah you can't
be in the group and just take you need
to go for contributor exactly very good
point and it's worked really well so we
we've introduced I've given my whole
list of all my clients to other Canaries
at a non IT engineer it's like here all
my clients who do you want to get
involved with and they do the same when
we launched I Southampton office has a
guy called Mattie Riley introduced us to
his client works he's got our business
called Osprey he introduced us to his
his clients and we did our first
placement the first two weeks really
give those guys some confidence down
there from a financial perspective we're
probably we're at least a hundred two
hundred grand a year better off by being
canaries by sharing each other's
customers and increasing buying power
wendy Merricks who's the CEO for Jamar
she estimates that it's generated her
three hundred grand plus really simply
in terms of cost savings and it's so
easy to think like just straight around
the face of it that you would be at a
loss rather than again you know I mean
if you've gone into a room full of ten
fifteen recruitment businesses maybe
some competitors in there or whatever
that is the typical mindset we've got IT
recruitment business now and we've had
situations where we've had too much on
and rather than another recruitment
agency fill that job because we would be
routing we give it to other Canaries
and say look this is something we need
some support with helpers you get the
deal don't obviously they wonder why
customs going forward but again we win
out of that yeah no I just think that I
think that's such a great point to make
that actually collaborating we can
actually all gain from it it doesn't
come at the detriment of Matt losing out
a bit or whoever else losing out a bit
actually we can all grow and achieve
together do you know I mean which i
think is it's part of the the mindset
that's changing with particularly what
I've experienced with the oven that
works out there and that I've been to
and like this podcast for example it was
and it wasn't maybe back in your day it
wasn't as easy for people just be
willing to share their challenges and
hopefully talk about their failures and
what they learned and their clients and
these types of things so you you meet
recruiters in a bar or at a bar and you
ask that they are everything's going
fine smashing it the reality of it is
they're not exactly you know share those
problems the group our conferences have
been great as well so we're point a few
conferences will get speech matter
experts in yeah you know we got a
hundred people in room so is it I don't
know many recruitment groups they're
able to work to do that how does it all
plan out Matt you've been in the game
long enough what's that how does this
all plan out long terms in terms of
things like we're just talking about
here and how that's like that wasn't
around and now it is and people wouldn't
to share and people getting free under
came or worth for business because they
weren't into clout collaborate to as we
as you as we've also spoke about the
people are a bit susceptible now hiding
behind the emails and links and these
lots of things like you've been in the
game long enough and and and you're a
very smart guy so I guess the future of
recruitment obviously it's a big big
thing to think about but how do you see
it evolving and what what the people
need to be thinking about to remain
future proof like what are you doing and
what what the some of the things that
you're thinking about long term we've
got a there's a lot happening at the
moment with you know our thirty-five
coming into the privacy of the next year
it's going to be massive and we're
expecting a lot a lot of disruption in
that space ultimately they're still
gonna be a lot of contractors need work
and a lot of quietly work done issues
the simians gonna land grab a lot of
that that disruption in that movie
and do you see that more as an
opportunity rather than there's a
massive opportunity mass again I talked
to your people out there in the wider
wider market and the panicky and the
numbers you get decimated yeah those
workers are gonna go somewhere and
hopefully they're on our books but yeah
so you know RT question where's
recruitment going we're gonna see
there's be more legislative changes like
you know r35 than ever before and I
think we're just gonna see more and more
stuff happening like that it's having a
plan for it and being creative I am
confident that recruitment is gonna go
more specialists so we've seen companies
do more in-house that's only gonna get
bigger as recruitment recriminations go
for an agency you know so just be super
niche create a real value in terms of
what you do so for us it's that inch
wide mile deep market so if I'm
competing one of my guys had you beaten
head-to-head with a generalist internal
recruiter we're always going to get the
edge yeah around that so I think the
whole solution based self so things like
Stainton the work we have started to
hire as a separate part of the business
more tech easier more developers so
we're gonna do more project-based work
around the customer taking a contractor
will say we'll deliver that and will
quote a deliverable for it so an answer
your question I think it's being smart
with legislators it's focused more on
the solution it's becoming more more
specialist to be honest with you I
remember I remember 20 odd years ago
that it was longer than that when job
serve coming in everyone said this is
the death of recruitment they're linked
in Khmer news this is the death of
recruitment recruitment he's a much much
bigger base now this 40,000 recruitment
business in the UK hello 7,000 so if
anything the industry is getting bigger
but don't necessarily think there's more
good recruitment area so it's like
there's a lot of there's a lot of
businesses out there but then we manage
around by people that have left smaller
business here bigger recruitment
companies or medium-sized businesses I
don't think the markets flooded weird
lots of good recruiters at the moment
before we finish them I think that's
that's really I really like what you
spoke about there before we finish
if I if I'm listening right now and I'm
I'm someone thinking about start my own
recruitment business what should they be
thinking about he's gonna send up a
boring day - sixty or thirty whenever
you look into launch get your
infrastructures and your finances in
order
yeah and by that I mean I found a great
accountant very early on whose
brilliance a total trust and confidence
with her we've got an FD that's been
with us since day one to do the finance
as well we put a great infrastructure in
place find a CRM that worked for us yeah
a good move middle office products and a
great back-office product that I can get
a - so it's putting all that
infrastructure in please
on day - thirty mmm so when the business
launches and a lot of people perhaps be
under contract so they can actually
trade before day one it's just on day
one just get your head down and do new
business yeah we're seeing organizations
struggle or startup struggle or even
fail for that matter is the business
owner is getting involved in only think
anything but recruitment yeah if you
were the MD of a directional business
you setting up with other staff at the
time plated people strengths mmm we've
got five people and our day one for me
everyone was doing three six day what
was evident very early on his people had
different strengths so I become a
hundred percent new business yeah
whereas a couple of the guys focus more
on a delivery pace was Muslim he was
just plain - what plaintiff strengths
and I the only other thing I'd say is I
I wrote a forecast for year one year two
year three what we delivered was nothing
nothing like the forecast we were at by
about fifty percent in year one so
wherever you think it's gonna cost you
add fifty percent yeah it's you know
it's great if you over deliver and you
over perform on your forecast then happy
days but you need to be ready in the
event that you don't do that I think I
think that's great advice mate so look
what you're excited about Mel what's
going on in there your word that you
wanna shout about we have the VQ
Christmas conference is taking place in
two weeks time so every year we take the
guys away so year one we were on a
budget so we did Dublin
because good laughs for her you too we
upped our game a little bit we took it
to st. Petersburg okay in Russia which
is beautiful for Christmas or they very
cold year three we technically want to
Dubai which is brilliant yeah yeah for
Dubai this year they've got no idea
where they can really so there it would
be told we go away for five days to pack
enough clothes for that period well it's
summer in beach so it's 28 degrees where
we're going at the moment but they've
got no idea where we go we are going to
do a big reveal on the I think it's the
10th of December where we're gonna get
the guys and let them know where the
girl yeah she's good so that's really
big for us Simone I saw Y saying look we
got a great year ever we really
appreciate the work the guys have done
the only bit I'm worried about is we're
gonna have to outperform ourselves next
year as well because this year is gonna
be particularly good really mm-hmm I
think when I worked in real creeping
business those moments are so special
aren't they those five days away get
some real solid time with each other
because it's bloody tough this job in it
and I'll thinking the moments are that
great when you can create them with the
business that you have I think they're
just so important to have that and
enable people to build some real solid
relationships and get some people that
they work with over the years I've hired
people who have never been to London let
alone be Europe or other parts of the
world so to get those kind of life
experiences as well to travel and just
experiences work in spending yeah so
we're not working spending quality time
with you your colleagues is pretty
important so so the final question I
have for you Matt is I asked it to
everyone you cannot like a phrase or a
word whatever comes to mind so if you
could communicate to all the recruiters
out there business owners and they take
on that this advice they'd implement it
tomorrow what would you say what comes
to mind if they were to to listen to
Matt and you could communicate to those
40,000 recruitment businesses mate what
comes to mind we're hiring I met a lot
of people that come into recruitment
know why they want to be in the industry
there's lot of people that just want a
job to get our work I think for the
managers it's just making the right eyes
in the first place to understand why
those people are going to be there and
what they want to get out of it like I
said I've always had a plan there's
always something that's driving and
pushing me on where is the business is a
vehicle to get to what I want mm-hmm
so there is a massive opportunity for
any trainee coming into the business
just be clear what they want to get out
of it and set your goals high if you're
21 at university and you just starting
out a career in recruitment think big
yeah there's funky first property in a
couple of years which is hired a gun
into our South Hampton office he was
amazing and she's just sat and wrote
this whole itinerary where she's gonna
go on holiday to Bali and Lombok in
Thailand and Malaysia and stuff like
that so that's the kind of real focus
that there are like people to have yeah
it may be that you know it doesn't
necessarily to be financial it could be
that somebody wants to just just be
number while succeed or something on
that which is having that goal and
sticking to it and for the managers just
finding out you know what you your staff
one that's bigger pleasure mate thank
you thank you really appreciate